TODAY'S INTERNET HEADLINES IT'S
RAPID REFRESH.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
THE FIRST COMEDIAN TO BUZZ IN
WITH THE CORRECT ANSWER GETS
THE STANDARD 100 POINTS.
IT IS SUPER BOWL THIS
WEEKEND.
(BLEEP) YEAH, AMERICA.
>> YEAH.
>> Chris: OF COURSE BRUNO MARS
WILL BE STAR OF SUNDAY'S
HALFTIME SHOW BUT SOME DEEP
DIGGING ON YOUTUBE REVEALS
FOOTAGE OF SIX-YEAR-OLD LITTLE
BABY BRUNO...
BRUNO MARSITO.
AS WHAT TYPE OF PERFORMER, A) A
BREAK DANCER FOR A HONOLULU
MATTRESS STORE OPENING?
PLAUSIBLE.
B) RAPPER FOR A CAPRI SUN
COMMERCIAL DOING "GRIN N JUICE."
>> THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN A GOOD--
>> Chris: GOING UNDER THE
MONIKER SNOOP PUPPY.
PUPPY BOWL!
OR C) LAS VEGAS' TINIEST
FILIPINO ELVIS IMPERSONATOR.
BRODY.
>> YOU KNOW, I SPENT A LOT OF
TIME IN LAS VEGAS, I HAVE
BEEN TO CIRCUS CIRCUS, I GET
COMPED THERE.
>> NOT A GOOD-- THAT'S NOT A
GOOD HOTEL.
>> WHY ARE YOU YELLING?
>> YOU HAVE A MICROPHONE
THAT WILL AMPLIFY YOU.
>> I HAVE BAD HEARING.
>> GOING TO GO WITH C, LAS
VEGAS'S TINIEST FILIPINO ELVIS
IMPERSONATOR.
>> Chris: THAT IS CORRECT.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> TOLD YOU!
>> Chris: I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
GUYS REMEMBER.
>> DON'T MESS WITH CIRCUS
CIRCUS.
>> Chris: I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
REMEMBER THE MOVIE "HONEYMOON IN
VEGAS," BUT HE WAS ACTUALLY IN
"HONEYMOON IN VEGAS," HERE IS
FOOTAGE FROM THAT.
>> ♪ FALLING IN LOVE
>> Chris: OH, WAIT.
I THINK THAT IS ACTUALLY THE
SUPER BOWL HALFTIME SHOW.
I GUESS WE COULDN'T GET THE
OTHER ONE.
>> THAT'S WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
SEE.
>> Chris: OKAY, COMMERCIALS ARE
TO THE SUPER BOWL WHAT
PICTORIALS ARE TO PLAYBOY, THAT
IS THE REASON THAT PEOPLE WATCH,
THEY WATCH FOR THE COMMERCIALS.
>> I THOUGHT YOU WERE GOING
TO SAY THAT IS THE REASON
PEOPLE MASTURBATE.
(LAUGHTER)
>> HAVE YOU SEEN THE PUPPY BOWL?
>> Chris: WELL, GUYS, YOU KNOW--
ALL RIGHT, WHILE THE SUPER BOWL
IS NOT UNTIL SUNDAY-- I LOVE
YOU, BRODY-- MANY OF THE
COMPANIES ARE ALREADY RELEASING
TEASERS FOR THEIR VERY EXPENSIVE
ADS.
COMMERCIALS FOR (BLEEP)
COMMERCIALS.
THIS COMMERCIAL TRAILER
ALREADY HAS 1.2 MILLION
VIEWS ON YOUTUBE, LOOK.
>> ALL RIGHT, THAT'S IT.
>> Chris: SO THAT IS A TEASER
FOR WHAT?
AN AD FOR CIALIS FEATURING TERRY
BRADSHAW AND PAULA DEEN?
>> YES, PLEASE, YES.
>> NO, IF IT'S FOR THAT ONE
IT'S LIKE GETTING INTO PAULA
DEEN IS LIKE DRIVING A CAR
THROUGH A DESERT.
(LAUGHTER)
A LOT OF WIDE OPEN SPACES.
IT'S DRY AND BARREN.
>> Chris: I'LL GIVE YOU POINTS.
OKAY, B) AN AD FOR TOYOTA
FEATURING FORMER N.F.L. PLAYER
TERRY CREWS AND THE MUPPETS OR
C) AN IMODIUM A.D. AD FEATURING
OPRAH, GAYLE KING AND DR. PHIL.
YES, SKLAR BROTHERS.
>> I THINK IT IS AN AD FOR
TOYOTA FEATURING FORMER N.F.L.
PLAYER TERRY CREWS AND THE
MUPPETS EVEN THOUGH I WOULD LOVE
TO SEE THE IMODIUM AD FEATURING
OPRAH, GAYLE KING AND DR. PHIL.
>> Chris: YOU ARE CORRECT IT IS
TERRY CREWS AND THE MUPPETS,
IT IS NOT--
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
WHAT A WEIRD JUXTAPOSITION OF
THINGS, LET'S SEE IS IT
DIARRHEA, BONERS OR THE MUPPETS?
WELL, I GUESS IT'S THE